I quite often use a third-party
Bluetooth bit of kit to listen to music
on my phone okay and it occurred to me
because I sometimes click on the on
youtube video when I see them and I want
to watch them that the audio and video
is out of sync so I think I tweeted it
actually and you you mentioned that you
might be able to help me out with it so
what's going on with bluetooth and why
are my videos and things out of sync so
I think we probably need to dial it back
a bit and actually think about what we
mean to say that video is in sync or if
it is out of sync because actually it's
not a straightforward answer if I'm
watching something on my mobile phone
and the video is in sync so these that
say there's a dot appears on the screen
and at the same time I hear a bleep by
the time the picture has reached my eyes
and the sound has reached my ears
there's going to be a delay between the
two because the sound travels slower
than the light does which is what we'd
expect but if I watching the same thing
on my computer screen or I'm sitting
back in the cinema making my popcorn
watching a movie the distance between
the screen and me is bigger as therefore
it's going to take longer therefore the
sync difference is going to be greater
so sync is not necessarily mean that
they haven't exactly at the same time
but they reach us in the way that we
perceive them as happening at the same
time which helps a bit because it means
that we a small amount of difference
will will not be noticed because we'll
just assume the thing is further away or
closer to closer to us and so we get
away of that what really will cause you
problems is if the sound as it's
happening now comes before the picture
that really confuses us the sound is
late compared to the visual is happening
now then that's fine it's just to a
point you will notice it's too far but
you'll just think the thing is slightly
further away than it actually is
well back to normal so I've got a pair
of Apple earpods which I bought just
well I need a new pair of headphones
where the one the Sennheiser's had
broken and I thought I try them see what
they were like I wasn't expecting too
much and turns out that musically
they're okay they're open back so they
they're not quite
noisy environment but the sound okay the
music's fine yes it's compressed audio
over Bluetooth link but generally I
enjoy them I like them other Bluetooth
headsets are available so I can just pop
them in they connect to my Mac and I can
start watching a video and everything
since income I think we got it close
enough to my microphone you probably
hear what's happening so you can hear it
in the video it's audio and video pretty
much in sync so there's obviously
something that Apple are doing and I'm
sure other manufacturers do which means
that I shall take these out and the
interesting thing is that since I took
them out it flicked it to be running on
the video as soon as I put them back in
it pauses slightly I think sort of
catches up and the video audio is back
in sync with the video through my
headphones let's stop that for a second
so we can see something that's going
there and that when it's coming out and
speak with the computer it's got to
adjust things compared to it's coming
through the headphones it's got to
adjust things let's think about what we
mean by video and audio being in sync
then we can sort of see how the things
got to go through the whole chain and
how it all ends up working so if we go
for the classic clapper board then the
way that old films used to be
synchronized is that someone was
standing for the camera and the
microphone clanking the clapper board
and you get a snap would you be able to
identify on the video frame and the
audio frame fracture on just on this to
synchronize these two cameras with a pen
and a piece of paper so what we'd expect
if that's the video frame that the audio
data for that thing would have the noise
such that we get the crack over the
thing if each other in that frame if it
happened too early we would hear the
audio before we saw the thing which
would look odd if happen too late then
it would sound out I think again all
that the thing should be far far away so
what we want to happen is that if when
we see this frame appear let's call it T
equals 0 we also want this piece of
audio to appear
t zero so we want them to start
appearing and that's a start play for
the whole generation which is going to
be what twenty milliseconds or so for
the whole thing we want twenty
milliseconds of audio to play from the
same point so what we want to happen is
the picture to arrive and the sound
coming to my ear to arrive at the same
time if they start off at the same time
and the audio processing practice the
sound takes it takes longer than the
time it takes the light to get me
relative to each other then they're
going to sound out a sink so we somehow
need to make sure that this and this
happen at the same time we've got an
interesting problem we've got an
interesting sink issue anyway in that I
have to effectively two separate
earpieces and to get the proper stereo
fact the audio has got to be
synchronized between the two of them
head friends
Shaunie's going to kill me for all this
sort of audio first thing I'm making and
doing so we've got to ensure that I hear
the 20 milliseconds of audio for a frame
at the same time as my eye sees that
frame so that's what we're trying to
make sure that the eye and the ear get
the same data at the same time if that
slips or even worse comes before it then
it's going to look odd why would we get
variations when we're using Bluetooth
headsets well we need to think about
what's going to happen when we sort of
do this and that we're going to have the
audio data here and so this is going to
be a series of zeros and ones and so on
to represent that data it's gonna be
about probably for a single frame about
8,000 or so bytes worth of data and then
when we send that over Bluetooth the
Bluetooth link is compressed if you look
at the packets that are being sent on
the air pods it's ending at 250 kilobits
per second AAC so the first thing that's
going to need to happen you can have the
audio data coming and then you're going
to run that through your compressor so
you're going to compress that into AAC
so you running through that you're a AC
compressor and that's going to take an
amount of time so there's going to be
time here so that's
cause X seconds to do that that's going
to then we split up into a series of
packets and so we're gonna break them up
into chunks and then we're going to send
these over the Bluetooth wireless stack
now probably inside this easily then
gonna be reassembled at the other end
probably you're gonna have some sort of
buffer here I mean I would and the
probably the same again so just so that
you if there's some sort of packet needs
to be resend gets lost you can resend
and you've got time to get on so it's
going to be a buffer which is going to
delay things by about eight d ii will
say there and then we're going to run
that through the DQ compressor so we're
going to decomp that and then we'll get
the data back the ones and zeros which
we can send to my ear so the signal path
coming over bluetooth is quite
complicated not only who got delays
because of transmitting it it's gonna
have to break things that the packets
are going to compress it decompress it
all that's gonna take time so we're
going to have this sort of processing
chain which is going to delay the audio
and this is probably going to be well
enough that you would notice it which is
what Shawn's experiencing when he's
watching YouTube for his cheap thing
reading I didn't say was cheap just
third-party it is yeah so that's the
first problem that Shawn's getting with
his Bluetooth headset is that he's
noticing like they're like so how can we
compensate for it well again if we think
about it what we want to happen is that
this audio data happens in the same time
section that it was at the same time
frame that the video is being played at
that frame with video is happening there
and so if we know exactly how long this
route is going to be then we can sort of
delay the video by that amount of time
so that even though the video is going
one route and the audio is going a
different route when they actually hit
my eyeball on my eardrum they appear to
have come at the same time so we delay
the video doing so yeah so possibly you
need to do that delay the video you may
find actually of course the the
interesting thing is that it may not be
as simple as that because the video and
the audio is coming from probably a
compressed video stream with a
compressed audio stream it may be that
actually you audio
quicker to decompress so you may find
that actually you've got more things
coming here but the thing we want is
that at the same point in time here we
want to get the same frame a video in
the same frame of audio so we need to
sort of get the video to be decoded and
transmitted to the eye as light at the
right time and the audio to be decoded
re-encoded transmitted over bluetooth
into the ear buffered possibly didn't
become sound and it happens at roughly
the same time i within less than
probably 10 to 20 milliseconds you
wouldn't notice it in that sort of
timeframe so you need some way to sort
of track how long each chain is for the
two things to happen and then work out
so that we then release them at the same
time so how do we keep these two things
that see how do we do that well for the
things that happens on our computer we
can write we rent the software we know
how the faster computer we've got is
we've got some idea for how long that
will take and again we can sort of
buffer things and realign them once we
know how things because we've got audio
which is probably labeled to a
particular frame we've got video which
is labeled to a particular frame we can
decompress them and put them into a
buffer and we can align them and then
start playing them out so here were that
bit out the bit that we don't know
because the time it takes for the light
to get there is going to be so small
it's going to be negligible so we can
assume that zero the bit we don't know
is the processing time for the audio
being sent through the Bluetooth chain
and getting to the ears now fortunately
the specifications for Bluetooth audio
which is the which is used on the air
pods is the advanced audio distribution
profile which runs on top of the
audio-visual distribution transport
profile and inside the a/v DTP the
profile there is an ability for the air
pods or any other Bluetooth headset to
send back details of the delay incurred
by sending the data so that you can send
data back saying okay this took X
milliseconds and if you know it's taking
X milliseconds to process the data you
can then adjust the video and all the
audio is necessary so they suddenly end
up back in sync this is basically a
feedback loop isn't it yeah I guess you
could call that in that the
so the device is telling you what it is
and then we can adjust it to do that and
we can get things to be sinkers and
actually it's set up so if it changes
for any reason for example I move
further ways or more Bluetooth
traffickers in the area so it's having
to resend him off and/or buffer it more
to get all the data then it can adjust
the delay and things can happen we can
actually see it because if I start the
video playing now we can hear and then
put my earphones in you'll see it pause
and then sort of catch everything back
to speed and it's back in sync so it
pauses briefly and then suddenly it
flicks and everything is back in sync
because it's had to adjust the actual
timings of the two signals and as I take
it out again it carries on playing
things it's actually a lot quicker to go
that way than it is to come back in here
if it is that I bought a cheap pair
where where is the fault is it in the
device or is it in the phone or is it
where is that because basically I
thought I've got an expensive nice pair
of headphones and I want to keep using
them but I want to use them wirelessly
yeah okay where's the phone
sorry sorry yet so it's an interesting
question it's not necessary that you
walk cheating there's lots of places so
for example it could be that the
software hardware combination on your
phone isn't bothering to synchronize
this and Apple have said when they've
implemented this they have and other
people have said they have that's one
possibility it could be that the device
you are using isn't returning the right
delay and so it's still actually it is
delaying it but it's not accurate enough
these various reasons work and we could
just really they haven't bothered
implementing it because they support an
earlier version of the profile that
didn't have theirs in so there's lots of
places where it could be I mean you
could sort of test you you could try the
device on a different source and see
whether that has the same problem you
could try it with a different pair of
headphones on your phone and see if that
has the same problem and so on say yeah
okay it's not necessarily that you
bought cheap device machine search sites
getting slowed down because well we
don't like what they're doing and this
is the argument that net neutrality
advocates would have which is that it
can't be at the whim of a commercial
provider a server
provider decided to favor some website
and it does kind of make green kind of
what I was expecting I mean I thought
this is a bit orange II just